eins zwei drei und los geht's Kopf Kopf
Hans Hans Fuß voller Körpereinsatz für
die deutsche Sprache
[Gelächter]
oh die Lehrer in der französischen
Kleinstadt vesul zieht durch die
Klassenzimmer und wirbt für seinen
Unterricht
die Fünftklässler müssen sich dieser
Tage für eine zweite Fremdsprache
entscheiden Deutsch ist nicht sehr
gefragt gilt als elitär und kompliziert
und wird landesweit nur noch von 15% der
Schülerinnen und Schüler gewählt dabei
hatten die beiden Länder einst mit dem
elisee-vertrag verabredet die
Verständigung zu verbessern für odinos
und prey ist das Jubiläum Anlass auf den
Missstand die Sprachlosigkeit aufmerksam
zu machen
ist nichts und ich habe davon das ist
eine politische Aufgabe denn es ist
schwer also einerseits zu feiern und
andererseits kennen Germanisten mehr in
Frankreich zu haben also ich denke
deutsche die Französisch lernen gibt es
immer noch aber es gibt schon ein Risiko
dass wir eines Tages fast keine
Germanistin in Frankreich haben und wir
wollen das unbedingt verhindern die
Folgen spürt der bereits jetzt unterwegs
zum nächsten College er muss an mehreren
Schulen unterrichten um auf seine
Stunden zu kommen und ist damit kein
Einzelfall in Frankreich herrscht akuter
deutschlehrermangel in der Pause
begleiten wir Ihnen seine Stadt wieso
ist eine der ersten die Anfang der 60er
Jahre einen deutsch-französischen
Schüleraustausch organisierte guten Tag
wie geht's
die Vereinigten Staaten von Europa sie
sind auf einem guten Weg kommentierte
der Nachrichtensprecher damals
euphorisch es gab schon Kriege zwischen
uns
blutige Kriege aber wir sind Beweis wir
konnten vielleicht Erzfeinde sein und
die besten Freunde sein das heißt alle
auf der Welt können auch auf uns schauen
und sehen dass jetzt Feinde beste
Freunde werden können
zwei Staatsmänner lagen sich vor 60
Jahren in den Armen Adenauer und de
Gaulle sie versprachen einander in
wichtigen politischen Fragen eine
gemeinsame Linie zu finden vereinbarten
Städte Partnerschaften und
Jugendprogramme
[Musik]
es leben Deutschland es lebe die durch
französische Freundschaft ein Bekenntnis
zueinander das zuletzt ausblieb
Staatsbesuch von Olaf Scholz im elisee
vergangenen Herbst eine lange Liste an
Unstimmigkeiten veranlasste die beiden
zum öffentlichen Schweigen
irritierenden Krisenzeiten in denen
Europa zusammenstehen sollte erklärt der
Historiker josephte Weg der in beiden
Sprachen zu Hause ist in dieser Hinsicht
ist es gut dass es dieses wichtige
Jubiläum gibt weil es zwingt einem
darüber wieder nachzudenken es ist klar
die Europäische Union hat heute 27
Mitgliedstaaten und es ist schon lange
nicht mehr der Fall dass Deutschland und
Frankreich alleine den Kurs des
eu-schiffes bestimmen können aber wenn
diese beiden Länder in eine andere
Richtung Rudern oder gar nicht im
gleichzeitig Bruder und dann kommt das
Schiff überhaupt nicht voran vor allem
seit dem Ukraine Krieg drängen
Sicherheit bereits und Energie Fragen
zum gemeinsamen Handeln doch sich
abzustimmen fiel den beiden offenbar
schwer in den vergangenen Monaten es gab
sehr viele Solo-Auftritte in seiner
großen
Europa-Rede in Prag von Olaf Scholz hat
der Bundeskanzler die
deutsch-französische Partnerschaft mit
keinem Wort erwähnt und für die
Franzosen ist die Aussöhnung mit
Deutschland die eigentliche resondert
der Europäischen Union das war ein
affron und so gab es auch die
retourkutschen aus Paris wir denken an
den abgesagten Ministerrat z.B wo macron
Scholz öffentlich auflaufen ließ dem
deutsch-französischen Bild Schaden
solche Auftritte hören wir auch beim
Krisentreffen der Deutschlehrerinnen und
Lehrerin Paris deren Verband erhöht nun
den Druck auf die Politik fordert mehr
Unterrichtsstunden und ein Sprachangebot
an allen Schulen in Frankreich
es sprechen ganz rationale Argumente für
Deutsch es ist eine wichtige Sprache auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt und natürlich für
Europa wenn wir immer
Vergleichen zwischen den deutschen
Schülern die die französische Sprache
lernen und den deutschen den
französischen Schüler die die deutsche
Sprache erlernen dann merken wir dass
wir viel weniger Stunden haben als die
Deutschen ist nicht so präsent wie
Englisch oder Spanisch in der Musik in
einem
in der im Fernsehen in den Serien ist
Spanisch sehr groß und das ist halt für
Deutsch kompliziert da müssen wir der
gegen ankämpfen
kannst du nicht willst du nicht dann
kannst du nicht Lehrer sompei tut dies
mit hip-hop-workshops in seiner Klasse
wird seit Wochen getestet und komponiert
im Mai treten sie gegen mehr als tausend
Schülerinnen und Schüler aus bei den
Ländern an ein Wettbewerb initiiert von
der deutsch-französischen Band
das kann für eine oder drei Personen
stehen und toi toi toi heißt auf Deutsch
so viel wie viel Glück und das wünschen
wir den drei Personen in unserem Lied
die Grenzen überschreiten wollen
wir müssen Sätze formulieren Wörter
nachschlagen wenn wir auf Deutsch Texten
die
älteren Schüler haben uns von dem
Projekt schon erzählt das klingt toll
auch dass wir dann auf der Bühne stehen
werden
man müsse die Schüler bei ihren
Interessen abholen über Umwege für die
Sprache begeistern sagt zum Bree in
vesul hat er damit Erfolg die Lieder
begleiten die Kinder auch noch nach
Schulschluss